well done in your film here thank you so
much so that you're getting top honors
tonight best actor for the national
board of Revenue go figure yeah they all
got the paycheck they all got the brand
envelope
um it's lovely yeah oh yeah I loved I
loved working on this film for probably
very obvious reasons the script was
extraordinary I was working with people
that I have a lot of love for
you and that I've worked it before and I
have a lot of history with and I got to
go home I got to go home to you know my
home country and
um and see parts of the country and
shoot and parts of the country that I
don't get to go to very often the iron
Islands Apple Island beautiful parts of
Ireland so Jose it was an extraordinary
experience so to have all this happen
look I'm getting I'm getting texts from
makeup artists that worked on the film
and getting texts from wardrobe people
that worked on the film so it's a sense
of community around it still to this day
it's not just all about us who are
perceiving things it's really not nah
it's very easy to feel like you're
representing others who are at home
having a look and enjoying these guys so
that makes it easier for me a former
co-star of yours Jeremy Renner was just
in a horrific accident yeah he had the
chance to chat yeah no been in touch and
reach out to me soon good I believe and
oh yeah all prayers are with them yeah
thank you